[Music]
in of all places knows they're like my
hero
but method by Power Rangers a woman
somehow sneeze out a ring shared lost 12
years ago what how big is our [ __ ]
nostril please know maybe she pooped it
out no I came out of her nose oh my gosh
she must get it in there for 12 years he
doesn't even know so this this girl
she's lying number what if he proposed
to her with a ring in the champagne she
swallowed it he's just like oh [ __ ] he's
never seen Eno's window like something
this small huh no we're talking about a
ring on your finger
what yeah I don't I can't even forgive
of Mario the R&B singer
that should look like two eyes
all right so Abigail she's 20 years old
she received this ring um for her eighth
birthday from her mom oh she was a kid
that's a grown-ass woman that makes
sense
baby was a baby ring she actually
thought all you all these years that one
of her friends that she would invite
over her house like probably stuck it up
her nose you know kids do that [ __ ] she
doesn't remember when many kids used to
get the one block Lego [ __ ] in their
[ __ ] nose cuz I remember they would
come over and stick it up and it they
would hold it like this and shoot it out
the only key that never shoved me got my
nose me neither
well you can't [ __ ] on my nose I almost
choked on a quarter though oh wow
I was laying in bed as a kid and for
some reason I remember this very well I
kept on trying to put the quarter on my
lip and blow it and flip it and catch it
in my mouth right there trying to do
that and then open my mouth to why
like that and that my mom came in and I
was just like coffee shoes what happened
was I didn't get my ass beat by almost
[ __ ] died a psycho
she's holding in her hand the ring that
she sneezed out
I'm BA ever go yeah I know it was gold
but it rusted over it I originally
looked like that
give her infection or pure cold this
whole time
hopefully it's tolerable doesn't rush
gold-plated or something so then um she
said that this entire time she never
ever felt like anything was weird or
different about her nose even after she
sees it out she still breathes exactly
the same way like she just doesn't even
know how I was in there
she never when she was picking her nose
when she was 8 her finger just just got
stuck up there I know that's so crazy
this is say now her friend that she
[ __ ] cut off is still pissed
oh you stupid [ __ ] ring she sees her
on the news she's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I
[ __ ] told you stupid nobody watches
[ __ ] it's a bit well she said she had
a group of girlfriends I don't think
she's singled any one of those you're
just bigger like oh one of them problems
every time anybody mentioned a range
just had a hell attitude for like
[ __ ] like 17 years of [ __ ]
do you want to go like to the skating
rink yeah you would like to go to a
[ __ ] ring wouldn't you I don't know
it is she a Hispanic what no no she's
from the UK oh she looks Hispanic is fun
she could be a London chola yeah hello
that there's a leak Oh
the rain is dripping through the roof
it's leaking oh oh it's a mouse no it's
rain it's dripping
oh [ __ ] it's right here oh no oh no I
gotta buy a new dope drum set what are
you under the trash cans what's that
you've got green one the green the green
one yeah I got a bucket I got a bucket I
got a bucket I got I'm talking about a
ring up and never got a pocket keep this
[ __ ] in there that's like filling them
she's been reading like crazy the
thunder sounded like a bomb went off
no a lot of people out there think that
oh my god is just right it doesn't rain
this often in LA and for like the past
for the past couple of weeks or three
weeks like for two weeks straight it was
like pouring in LA without stop every
[ __ ] day which doesn't happen a lot
here so that's why a lot of these
buildings don't really prepare for this
type of [ __ ] the big I need that's the
one yeah this is a better idea
yeah I don't listen to me ever
June ever told you that was Linda I
didn't know I told you I just wanted a
back listen rolling good I want to get
uh Bayless gondol there days that's the
beef one right be Mexican fuh hope you
guys are enjoying this episode the [ __ ]
was the article beltless how about the
article the nose ring let's put hella
ads in this section
this story is about Abigail was the ring
that she had up her nose
remember that called Mexican Susan hi
yes she is
that injections yes that is injections
isn't it not very good injects famous
Thompson and she's from the West
Yorkshire yeah West Mexico dude West
Mexico where she's Mexican is she
British Mexican or English Mexican yes
she is
can British on the cheek in English
because if she's not then her injections
made her look really latina like might
not even like Mexican British British
right okay this is Mexican British got
them I'm glad you got the facts straight
oh my god I don't know her whole life
story
Mexican Welsh so you guys like people
from the UK a lot of girls they look
like this yeah cuz they all trying to be
like the Kardashians you know like this
is their luck I miss the days when
people just I don't know but even girls
in America it's like that's just a look
now yeah why or if you're gonna get
injections chill on it a little bit
hello human yeah but everyone around
them looks the same way so they they
look different yeah so they all just
blend in but then when they go out into
oh [ __ ] what people say man some of this
stuff nowadays like I can't they look so
different
dude those body surgeries and make them
look like a wisdom tooth yeah it's crazy
when they get like the brazilian
butt-lift but they make their hips
[ __ ] hugh yeah like wisdom tooth
dominant Asian stuff now is getting
crazy man and it's weird because and
I've said this to where it's just like
the the my issue with it is that there's
so many women who are like high
influencers they talk about loving
yourself being body-positive but they
they always say it in a way that that
promotes how they want to live their
life and now that about saying that oh
you should follow this to well guess
what [ __ ] not everybody has $30,000 to
[ __ ] fix their [ __ ] face you know
I'm gonna career to get surgery don't
you [ __ ] dare you [ __ ] if you if you
do I'm gonna find that surgery I'm gonna
kill him I want them to be honest and be
like yo man surgeries the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
tell people if you want to get surgery
[ __ ] do it happy that's very
different from life man I was a work in
the gym and then it's like it's going a
big ass it'll [ __ ] big ass titties
and everything with a little stomach and
it's like [ __ ] you lying with some
tooth girl dies [ __ ] creepy oh [ __ ]
oh so yeah and that shit's [ __ ] up
because girls are working really hard at
the gym and they're like see I'm not
done doing the serve because I'm lazy
surgery you're not doing the surgery
what surgeries do they do over there I'm
planning on doing I want to get it right
I want to get I want to do like the
facial contouring no yeah no I'm not
gonna be like a condom noona do they
just [ __ ] get scissors and cut the
skin off your [ __ ] won't depends on what
you get done like they um they transfer
the fat or if they need to or like you
take it out or like they shave it
whatever I don't know yet
all I know is I ain't paid for it I'm
good you're gonna get a discount face
reconstruction no it's some sponsorship
don't do it I'm bringing you with me so
you can translate for me yeah
that sounds dangerous Gina no dude this
is like the plastic surgery capital of
the world dude I know but then it might
be like one of the cheaper places in
that popular street well I mean the
thing with these if you get if you were
to get surgery you have to do your
research to the on the right doctors
just don't do it yeah what what problem
do you view that you have that needs to
be fit it's not a problem I feel like
I've never hated my face I just want to
enhance there's nothing to enhance your
face is perfectly fine that means you
don't love it 100% cuz I see you my face
with no [ __ ] flaws but everyone else
does that's their problem for me what I
do what I always tell people it's like
you have like one vessel in life or like
everyone's a piece of art and make it
how you want to look like like I'm for
sure never gonna go overboard without
taking steroids one vessel I'm gonna
turn it to 300 pounds you shut the [ __ ]
up you can't do that fine it's just
never gonna end well and don't you dare
dr. president I would have stopped at my
boobs no or I want to keep going from my
don't you dare touch your [ __ ] face
if you all could do something to your
face I'm gonna slice those surgeons
hands off
because you're [ __ ] cute dude of
course I've always said you're cute dude
do you know it's gonna make it worse
because we know people that had a young
age they did work [ __ ] them up what
something like you're young still god
damn it doctor for dead well it's one of
those things too like if someone would
tell me like hey you need to get plastic
surgery I will never be like why you
don't need it it's like it's your body
you can do all right if it makes me
happy well then you really don't need it
though than like I tried and technology
isn't that good yet I'm saying get it
have you seen the Kardashians just wait
yeah they look [ __ ] just wait their
waist looks [ __ ] the small way that
was weird but their face looks [ __ ]
well I see this though I don't when you
get work done it's great for pictures
but in person but impersonal it's like
there's people who have done some you've
seen people like people don't even
realize that a lot of people have
plastic surgery why does it look like oh
[ __ ] it why do people look like lizards
when a plastic surgery [ __ ] lizard
liberties that look insane that's that's
like a body dysmorphia to think it looks
very accustomed to your face now and
then you come back with a different face
I have a new friend it's really crazy
different good cuz I'll never go
overboard with it that's the thing I'm
gonna you know what interests me those
those ladies that go overboard with the
titties then I gotta get bigger bigger
bigger didn't they look like their
titties are like here there's a
difference between getting like good and
then overboard cuz you've seen nice fake
titties before yeah and then I have a
lot of friends who like job like stupid
of course I have yeah I've have friends
who'd like just wanted to fill up their
bra
Yeah right here bro yeah they're full
now pretty cool
just wanting a little tweak and then
like [ __ ] like full-on cat lady [ __ ]
that mmm sometimes I'm interested though
why do they think their titties are too
small wonder triple D's those are scary
they still think it's too small just can
like the weird addictions and [ __ ] like
that they'll be like man I gotta go
bigger and then the doctor is like yeah
we could go bigger it's like you
enabling son of a [ __ ]
you sold your [ __ ] soul to the devil
I feel like doctors who do that sure
like [ __ ] up doctors they don't give a
[ __ ] they're like I know what I'm gonna
do it so I could say goodbye to your
face yeah you probably wouldn't be able
to tell that's how subtle I'm getting it
oh I'll be able to tell everything all
right because I will never ever forget
it I like your face now I've known that
face for how many years and you change
your [ __ ] face Oh
[Music]